let's talk about the eight unexpected
benefits
of iodine now iodine is this trace
mineral now you don't need a lot of it
but you definitely need the right amount
and if you don't have the right amount
all sorts of things can happen in your
body simply because every single cell in
the entire body needs iodine not just
the thyroid now your thyroid is the
iodine hog it'll tend to suck up a lot
of the iodine you have and not leave
much for anything else so just because
your thyroid is working and you don't
have any thyroid symptoms doesn't mean
you have
ample amounts of iodine so it's not just
about having adequate amounts of iodine
it's about having enough for all of your
cells and unfortunately the current
rdas for iodine are way too low it's
recommended that we need about 150
micrograms per day
but people in japan which have very
little rates of breast cancer ovarian
cancer prostate cancer are consuming a
hundred times that amount
but it's mainly from sea cal because sea
kelp is one of the best sources of
iodine now i want to be totally
transparent with you i do have a dr berg
brand seek help and yes i do have a very
strong bias on my own brand as far as
the quality and where it's sourced from
but here's my point a lot of people are
deficient in iodine and unfortunately
it's just not in our foods anymore
unless you're consuming foods from the
ocean like shellfish or sea kelp like
seaweed etcetera now there's a really
simple way to determine if you're
deficient in iodine simply go to your
local drugstore and get a little bottle
of iodine and some cotton balls okay and
then what you do is you take a little
iodine put it on a cotton ball and rub
it either on the inside of your upper
arm or your forearm or the inside of
your leg roughly in about a two inch
diameter now make sure it doesn't touch
your other clothes because it can stain
your clothes and you could put a
band-aid over it if you want but if
you're deficient
within one hour
it'll be gone the stain will be gone
because your skin absorbs it so if after
an hour it's still like orangish yellow
then you're usually not deficient but i
would say probably over a billion people
on this planet have an iodine deficiency
and a lot more of them have a
subclinical iodine deficiency that might
not show up
if people are just focusing on the
thyroid symptoms i mean our bodies
utilize iodine for many different
reasons
one really interesting way it uses
iodine is
detoxifying mercury
lead when you get enough iodine and
you're exposed to lead and mercury
you'll see higher levels coming through
the urine because your body is able to
get rid of it also in your body's
ability to detoxify fluoride
and bromide okay which is in a lot of
the flower products which has the
ability to deplete iodine but of course
if you've been watching my videos you
don't have to worry about that because
you're not consuming refined grains so
what i want to do with this video is
show you all the unexpected
benefits of having sufficient iodine
that really don't have a lot to do with
the thyroid okay number one its ability
to shrink cysts okay cysts that are
developing in the breast tissue like in
fibrocystic breast
cysts on the ovaries
cysts in your uterus and of course cysts
even on the thyroid these cysts that are
created
if they just don't have enough iodine
over time they develop in two nodules
and they can also develop into cancer
that's why iodine has anti-cancer
properties and iodine is really good at
regulating
estrogen dominance if too much estrogen
iodine can help bring that down to a
normal level okay number two i've done a
whole video on this iodine helps to
reduce the size of skin tags and warts
if you haven't seen my video on that i
put that down below all right next one
is in its ability to help break down
connective tissue in a condition called
duperton's contracture that's a
situation where you have scar tissue on
some of your tendons in your finger and
your fingers just like stuck you'd want
to put topical iodine on there each day
and within about a month you should see
some pretty good results and that
relates to the next benefit
scar regeneration so let's say for
example you have a keloid
or
some surgical scar
and you put iodine into that scar each
day over a period of about a month
you're going to see some pretty cool
results you might even see hair growth
that occurs right over the scar now if
you're concerned about it staining your
skin they do have a type of iodine that
is clear that doesn't stain your skin
but iodine helps break down
scar tissue all right the next
unexpected benefit would be on your mood
if you have depression iodine many times
can improve it now
they don't know exactly why it could be
because it's improving your thyroid
gland which can bring up your mood or
could be involved in certain um
neurotransmitters in your brain they
don't know but iodine can actually bring
you up mood wise all right next one it
can help shrink
uh stones in your parotid glands now
your product gland helps you make saliva
so having enough iodine can even prevent
those stones from occurring iodine can
help reduce hot flashes as well as heavy
menstrual cycles
because of what it does to estrogen it
helps to balance estrogen and last very
cool effect is it can help reduce cystic
acne which by the way is many times
related to
too much estrogen now the next video i
want you to watch is a more
comprehensive video about iodine which i
think you'll very much enjoy even though
it was a very old video so check it out
i put it right here
you